mike is with us in Nebraska hey Mike
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks taking my call sure what's up
well my wife and I have just started the
baby steps on step two and we've sat
down we've got the budget put together
got a plan but my question for you
she is not 100% on board with stopping
the 401k contributions from from what we
put together you know we're about
$75,000 in debt not including the
mortgage and from what we put together
we can do we can get it done in about
three years or less
what's your household end go down soon
I'm conservative would be 160 number Y
in the crud would make you three years
to pay off $75,000 making 160 $2,500
mortgage $1,400 in childcare was $25,000
a year out of 160 mm-hmm
you ought to do this in a minimum
maximum of two years that would be ideal
you guys know you guys have cut nothing
out of your lifestyle in this budget
okay and you're still and you're still
contributing to the 401ks
I am NOT he's contributing about seven
percent now employer matches about three
now and you know I think her she's just
she's very conservative and I think
she's just afraid that you know if we
stop that you know we're a mess out on
ton of money yeah so well if you if you
don't stop if you don't stop you're
gonna miss out on more money because
then all the data says all the data of
all the millionaire's that we've studied
says that 80 to 90 percent of them did
not use consumer debt they get out of
consumer and they stay
consumer debt and the fact that you're
limping along making a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars a year with consumer
debt because of her theories about being
conservative are holding you back to
wealth building is what amounts to
here's the thing how long y'all been
married about seven years now okay the
reason you got married was focus you
focused on her she focused on you the
things you focus on you win at and the
problem with her theory is is you're not
focused I understand the math I'm an
absolute math geek I can virtually do
compound interest in my brain I've been
doing this a long long time I love the
power of compound interest I agree with
her what she has not seen yet is the
she's not looking at your all's budget
with you and if she is she's not
emotionally grasping that this is a
temporary stop to the 401 K for two
years how old are you - 31 and 30 yeah
and so if by the time you're 33 years
old you have zero debt except your house
and you make a hundred and sixty
thousand if you can't become wealthy by
sixty years old you're mentally deficit
I mean really that's absurd right right
so I mean be like falling off a freakin
log with no payments at all anywhere
except your house making a hundred and
sixty thousand you should be able to
load the 401 k's up to fifteen percent
like we teach and start your kids
college like we teach pay extra on the
house and get it paid off in ten years
like we teach and you should be multi
millionaires by the time you're in your
sixties like we keep like we teach
that's what the math says and this this
is by a hyper conservative margin hyper
conservative hmm as you make almost 3x
than
on average income in your household
right and you're only 30 G's right so
the bottom line is is that the the
problem that she's facing is she has not
spent enough time to emotionally grasp
the full play of what we're talking
about she's just looking at the budget
and her husband's gotten all excited
about this and she doesn't know if y'all
are really going to do this or not
and so just in case I'm gonna keep doing
my 401k because I'm not sure we're gonna
do this so I'm not sure it's gonna work
and I haven't really understood how it's
gonna work other than I think we ought
to get out of debt that'd be nice mm-hmm
but there's not a complete the last 10%
of truth where she grasps emotionally
and says this is gonna be worth it
because it's gonna lead us to tens of
millions of dollars and that's what's
going on so basically you're trying to
you know last summer I had my ski boat
out with my kids and when I dropped
anchor in the cove because we were
swimming and I tried to drive off with
the anchor out and the boat ran really
slow oh it we go but it was slow and
that's what you're doing you're trying
to run run the boat with the anchor out
and so stop pull the anchor in go go go
that's what you do hey man thanks for
the call